What for?
For fun. I'll do anything for fun.
How much can a single expression convey? Steven
Yeun is one of my favorite actors working
right now and one of my favorite performances
from him is his restrained ambiguous work
as Ben in Lee Chong Dang's Burning.
Jung-Su. Do you like pasta?
I'm not going to spoil the movies I talk about
in this video but here's some context for
this one: Jung-Su has randomly reconnected
with a friend from school, Hae-mi who he has
an unexpressed crush on, meanwhile Hae-mi
while she's off on a trip abroad becomes friends
with wealthy and mysterious Ben who she's
interested in. It's classic Love Triangle
stuff but there's another layer here. There's
this scene where they all go to dinner with
some of Ben's rich friends and Hae-mi at Ben's
encouragement is demonstrating a dance she
learned while she was traveling Jong-Su is
watching her and then looks over at Ben and
catches him yawning and then Ben gives him
this look. There's so much in this brief moment;
a feeling that he doesn't really care, a kind
of contempt, that she's just a play thing
to him. But there's also this element of bringing
Jun-Su into that feeling. There's a "you know"
sort of aspect to the look that feels like
it's trying to make Jung-Su complicit in Ben's
behavior. Something that is found only in
Steven Yeun's performance, that alludes to
a whole world of subtext that eventually becomes
very important to the film.
This video is sponsored by Curiosity Stream.
Sign up for the Curiosity Stream plus Nebula
bundle and watch my full companion video for
this video about screen presence on Nebula
You have nothing.
When people talk about "best performances"
in film a lot of stuff comes up, and a lot
of it is this kind of thing. The big evocative
roles, the roles that require the actor to
transform themselves into a character completely
in some way.
For the Oscars it's even better if that transformation
requires some kind of challenging element
like weight loss, prosthetic makeup, or an
accent.
Like so much of the rest of the Oscars it
can sometimes feel like the awards go to most
acting and not necessarily best acting.
I think one of the reasons The Joker has become
such an enduring screen character isn't necessarily
because he's just a more compelling villain,
but because he's become a character that is
a playground for bold expression that the
regular boundaries of performance may not
allow.
And actors enjoy lining up and taking their
swing at the role almost as much as audiences
enjoy watching those swings.
And this video is not about how these kinds
of performances are bad.
I love an... "I've abandoned my boy" ...moment
as much as anybody.
In fact my favorite actor Tilda Swinton, while
she definitely can play subtle roles, often
doesn't.
One of the reasons I love her work is in part
because she's willing to go way overboard
and transform herself into all manner of absurd
character for even small supporting roles.
So I'm not here to bash that kind of acting
I think it's great.
But in all the praise for this kind of showy
and transformational acting I think some of
the best performances or moments of performance
can get overlooked.
So I want to showcase an aspect of performance
that I think is less recognized but no less
impressive.
These moments are not ones where the actors
transform themselves but ones where they seem
to disappear into a character where you can
no longer see the actor on screen performing
and instead just see their character feeling
the emotion of the drama.
Often what sets these kind of performances
apart is the subtlety with which these actors
can convey deep rich and complex emotion with
their faces and their bodies.
They've embodied the character to the point
where they communicate what they want to communicate
through the character not just with line delivery
but with even the tiniest of expressions.
Sometimes these subtler reactions and expressions
can play a very important role within the
story itself: besides the Steven Yeun character
in "Burning," Daniel Kaluuya in "Get Out"
is another great example of this.
Kaluuya plays the big emotions in this movie
well, but even more importantly his reactions
to the world around him gives the film subtext
a lot of weight and helps guide the audience
into the absurdity of the experience.
"Such a privilege to be able to experience
another person's culture"
-like the way this look right here telegraphs:
"yeah I know what you *really* mean.
The exact subtext of a lot of Daniel Kaluuya's
reactions in the first part of this movie
are just as important as any of the lines
the other characters are saying.
Another recent performance I think is really
great is Florence Pugh in Midsommar.
She nails the big outpouring of emotion necessary
for certain scenes but I think almost more
impressive is her command of a subtler, smaller
moments.
The film opens with the death of her family
and look at this moment where a friend brings
it up:
"also I I never had the chance to tell you
but I was I was so very sorry to hear about
your loss"
"oh"
"what happened I mean"
-I the way her expression sort of melts into
a subtle grief... It's the kind of thing that
looks like it could only really be an automatic
reaction to a sudden memory or realization.
There's a similar moment from a bit part in
The Darjeeling Limited that always gets me:
The three brothers show up at their father's
mechanic to pick up his car on the way to
his funera,l and the way the mechanic subtly
responds to finding out the father died:
"you'll have to wait another week I left a
message"
"yeah he didn't get the message Mr. Whitman
is dead you understand."
"Jimmy Whitman?"
...For some reason to me one of the saddest
things in the film.
Continuing on this theme of grief Rooney Mara
conveys it powerfully in David Lowry's "A
Ghost Story."
Sometimes grief can leave you frozen in shock
and that seems like it should be easy to pull
off for an actor you just don't move.
But there's a tension and involuntary element
to what looks like genuine shock that is different
from just not moving
and here....
there's the smallest involuntary twitch that
somehow sells this moment as more authentic.
One of the reasons I think I'm drawn to these
kind of subtle moments is that I think they
often convey a kind of complexity of emotion
that isn't necessarily there in bigger outbursts.
Pulling off the big outbursts in a way that
feels authentic is certainly a challenge,
but what about the nuance of expressing repressed
emotion?
What about when you want the audience to perceive
that the character is feeling an emotion and
also perceive that the character is trying
to hold that emotion back?
Amy Adams does it here in Spike Jones' "Her"
in this moment where her character wants to
cry but is also obviously trying not to.
"Charles and I split up."
"what?"
"yeah really"
Or what about the complexity of multiple emotions
arising at once?
Oscar Isaac nails this in HBO's remake of
"Scenes From a Marriage." In this scene he
and his wife, played by Jessica Chastain,
decide to keep an accidental pregnancy.
"Ava'll be thrilled."
"And your parents."
"oh God yeah"
-And this little moment of expression...
...is amazing.
The amount of fear hope and trepidatious joy
that are all somehow fighting to come out
at once, even while he attempts to hold them
back is incredible to me.
I find this kind of thing compelling because
in my experience I think this is what a lot
of real life emotion is actually like. Sure
there are the big yelling and punching the
wall moments for some people, sometimes, but
I think far more frequently there's emotion
that people are trying to conceal or that
is a tangled mix of different emotions instead
of just one big one.
Riz Ahmed has this great moment in "Sound
of Metal" where he asks his mentor and sobriety
sponsor for money:
"I was wondering Joe I don't know if it's
possible, I need money."
"Just to buy back my RV you know me me and
Lou is all we have."
...and the way grief and shame seem to bubble
to the surface while he fights it back hits
me every time watching this.
People talk a lot about range in acting as
the ability to play different types of characters
but I think there's also a kind of range in
terms of intensity.
We all know Joe Pesci for the sinister intensity
that he has in "Goodfellas:"
"funny how? I mean what's funny about it?"
"he's a big boy he knows what he said. What'd
you say funny how?"
This guy is right on the edge. You don't want
to mess with him. He feels like he could snap
at any moment and he's genuinely terrifying.
"tell me tell me what's funny"
So it's impressive to me that in "The Irishman"
his character is no less sinister and threatening.
"There's been a change instead of uh we're
going up right away we're gonna hang around
tomorrow morning and then go up drive up."
"But I told Jimmy that we were gonna be up
in the morning I told Jimmy we were going
to be up in the morning."
"I know"
Even though the intensity of the performance
is dialed way back until it almost disappears.
"We got to go there I mean I gotta go I got
I told him I'd be there."
"Frank. We did all we could for the man."
The fact that he can convey something so similar
through completely different levels of intensity
is why he's one of the greats.
When I talk about these kinds of subtle expressions
I think rarely are they a very conscious choice
by the actor.
I don't think Rooney Mara is acting that scene
thinking "my neck is going to twitch and that's
going to make it feel more real."
Rather this kind of subtlety is the result
of the actors finding a way to actually experience
or feel the emotions they're trying to convey
and the subtle micro expressions are the result
of that.
But one of the reasons I've never talked about
acting despite the fact that I've made over
100 videos about film and television now is
because the craft is kind of a mystery to
me.
When I listen to actors talking about their
craft there's not a consistent approach that
wins out and seems to be the best and when
actors talk about how they accomplish these
kinds of performances.
It's often very esoteric and it's all about
arriving at a point of authenticity and sometimes
completely differing techniques can get you
there.
Sometimes they refine things through extensive
rehearsal and sometimes actors find that in
the spontaneity of a first take.
It's kind of impossible to reverse engineer
a performance just by looking at the screen
and trying to figure out what the actor did
to get there.
And so I think talking about technically what
makes for good acting is a pretty difficult
feat.
All I can really do is look at these performances
and assess how authentic or unforced it feels
to me.
I think a lot of these techniques are just
finding a way to access genuine emotion and
then this very realistic expression comes
out of that.
That said if there are performers out there
who have this kind of conscious control of
minute micro expressions in a way that feels
involuntary... I mean that's almost more impressive.
There are so many fantastic examples of this
kind of performance out there and this isn't
meant to be a definitive list or a list of
the best examples of this these are just specific
examples that have stuck with me because they
impacted me in a certain way and as I was
looking through all these examples and trying
to understand what quality it is that allows
this kind of subtle expression to come through
in these performances I noticed that a lot
of these performances have a quality that
I would call screen presence I think screen
presence is an interesting idea and it's one
I wanted to explore a little more thoroughly
so I made a companion video all about that
that is available exclusively on nebula putting
this video on nebula a streaming service made
for and by creators allows me to explore this
topic in depth with longer examples without
having to worry so much about copyright claims
if you don't have nebula click the link in
the description below you can get it for an
entire year for less than fifteen dollars
using the Curiosity stream plus nebula bundle
there's so much great content on nebula that
you can't get anywhere else in addition to
the companion video here about screen presence
you can also find Lindsay Ellis's nebula original
about how the Lord of the Rings films were
adapted I have a podcast that I do with my
fellow video essays Tom vanderlunden from
like stories of old called Cinema of meaning
and if you listen to that on nebula you get
episodes early and AD free and you also get
a bunch of bonus exclusive episodes that are
only for nebula listeners check all of that
out and you can get access to my normal YouTube
content available ad free and early on nebula
nebula is great because there's no advertising
and no algorithms which changes the incentives
for the Creator we can focus on making the
best content possible without having to focus
on what's going to get the most clicks and
I have a great deal for you if you want to
sign up curiosity stream another service has
partnered with us to create a bundle curiositystream
has their own extensive library of great educational
documentary and non-fiction content and when
you sign up for curiositystream using my link
below you'll get curiosity stream and nebula
for free with curiositystream for less than
15 a year go sign up right now by clicking
the link on the screen or in the description
below go to curiositystream.com thomasflight